foreign
in Gainesville Florida what's up Lauren
hey how we doing
I'm doing well how are you excellent
excellent so what's up
um so I kind of wrote down just the gist
of it
um so I am a special education teacher
and have been at my current school for
about three years now I love my
classroom my students I love working
with the other adults in my classroom
however about a month ago I had to
report two of my co-workers to my
Administration as well as DCF for things
that I saw and heard them do towards a
child who is non-verbal and autistic
what'd they do I know I did
um I don't know how much I can really
say
um but it was just something out at the
playground
um and it dealt with
um a potential video of a student
um showing some private parts
um I didn't know if there was a video
and so that's why I kind of had to
report it
um but also I heard some things about
some retaliation of why that student was
so upset in the first place by a
different teacher
um and then my principal is actually the
one to tell me to report it to DCF um
there there wasn't an investigation with
BCF but the school did an investigation
and then they basically just returned
back to school about
um three or four days after the incident
so was the finding
that you thought something really bad
had happened turns out something really
bad didn't happen no part no harm no
foul or did the school find things and
sweep it under the rug
I don't know I never knew anything about
what the investigation you know resulted
in
sometimes depending on and again I don't
know your state and I don't know whether
you're in a union all that kind of stuff
but often the complaintant has a written
response that comes to them
okay that makes sense so if you if you
um and I know this is especially an
assault um investigations if you
complained about something
um you made a complaint I say
complaining like you're whining not like
that but you you made a complaint that
somebody
um
uh sexually assaulted you or was it had
inappropriate contact with you
you would get after a certain amount of
time 30 days 60 days 90 days you would
get a written report of the findings
even from like the school district yes
okay I don't know if that applies in
Florida I don't know if that applies in
your particular District especially to a
report like this
why didn't the school district I mean
why didn't uh
what it's CPS from from Texas what's it
called there
DCF DCF why did they not do any sort of
Investigation
um they just kind of send an email after
saying that there wasn't enough to go
about it okay so look further into it
okay based on based on what I was
telling them okay cool so I'm guessing
you're a pariah now
um yes yes
and that's basically my question
um because like I know I did the right
thing everyone has told me that um I did
what my Administration told me to do
um but not just from the two people
um but
my whole kind of special education
preschool team
um pretty much will either tell me that
I did the wrong thing or when I say hi
to them in the hallways they just stare
at me and ignore me
um my actual like para paraprofessionals
in my classroom they are on my side if
you will
um and so we're just kind of in our own
little classroom and the other couple of
classrooms they do their holiday party
without us they
um kind of just stay on their side so
it's kind of getting a little lonely
absolutely and a bit awkward yeah
because you're the snitch now Lauren
yes geez Louise Okay so
here's a perfect world
a perfect world is you see something
like that
and in your mind some a couple of
teachers are taking advantage sexually
explicit videos of a student with
special needs any student
and they're laughing about it they're
making jokes about it and you
immediately flip your lid as you should
as any adult with a pulse should and you
report that your principal tells you to
report it they come back and turns out
it was the whole thing was a
misunderstanding in no way was what was
what you thought was happening actually
happening then those adults come to you
and they're like hey what happened why'd
you report us and you say man because of
this and this and they're like oh geez
I totally get it hey thank God you care
this much about students young people
children
and that's not what happened at all in
the future just holler at us dude and
we'll be we'll be the first to tell you
and there would be some sort of uh we
talked about on the show probably about
a year ago there was a dad who was
walking out of like a TJ Maxx or
something and his little child was doing
a temper tantrum right and then the guy
walking in stopped
and the dad said Thank God somebody
stopped even though my kids don't temper
tantrum I'm just getting out of the
store I'm glad that somebody cared
enough to stop that's what I hope that's
the way I hope adults Act
you know what I mean
um and if I didn't do anything wrong I
shouldn't care about an investigation
why would I care about that I didn't do
anything so that's how it would I would
hope it works in a perfect world we
don't live in that world we live in a
world where it's I told my son the other
day who's in seventh grade he's like I
can't wait till middle school's over and
I was like I got I got to break some bad
news to you brother this is the rest of
your life when people will be like oh my
gosh what are you wearing why are you
wearing this is that how you cut your
hair oh my gosh that's gonna be the rest
of your life and so
you've heard me say not by your hand but
in your lap you were minding your
business at work and all of a sudden you
saw something that was the core epitome
of evil you reported it you did the
right thing you didn't do anything about
I mean you didn't cause any of this but
it landed in your lap you responded to
it
and now you have to own the consequences
of having done the right thing which
often are miserable
yes right and so it sounds like the
choices you have before you
already go to another school
or to make peace with I did the right
thing and it at the end of the day my
Integrity wins out and over a long
enough period of time
people will make their way back to
somebody who is of character
I can't tell you to quit your job
I know but you said the L word you said
you're lonely and I hate that word
and part of me doesn't want to see
somebody like a group of immature
bullies win
by you leaving
the other side of it is
um I don't
I don't want you to have an already more
miserable life than you got right now
for doing the right thing if you're
trying to love and care for kids
yeah you know what I mean and so there's
the old say you know Jay-Z's like just
brush his shoulders off dude or you know
Jesus like dust her sandals off like I'm
out there's a part of me that's just
like I'm out
like if this is how it's gonna be man
for me doing the right thing then
God bless you all have fun and I'm just
gonna think a second thing of it
um what's Magic about this place that
you don't want to leave or is it just
the principle
no it's
no it's um the people in my classroom so
I have like four adults who help me um
um all have basically told me that they
want to stay in my classroom for next
year that they don't want to go to these
other classrooms
um you know because they probably have
absolutely little to no influence over
that
um well that's where our principal is
actually pretty cool like we do
um put forth what we kind of want and
she usually tries to keep it how um we
kind of request it to her
um we kind of do have some say over what
students we have in our classrooms and
um what adults have you gone to talk to
your teacher I mean your principal and
asked to say hey man things are really
awful is there
I don't know if they've got any ideas or
they can bring people together or go for
a retreat or some some way to heal some
of this
um but it may just be adults acting like
adults and it's just hard I mean adults
acting like children it's just hard
yeah they had um I brought it up kind of
within the first couple of days because
it was a lot worse
um people were a lot more obvious and
some names were being called
um and so they had brought in and kind
of talked about it um since then it's
more of a professional ignoring
um if you will they put it on you like
you'd be the grown-up and just go on
about your day
yeah kind of I mean there's so Hey
listen there's something to be said for
that there's something to be said for
dude I'm like I'm gonna come here and
love these students take care I got a
core group of professionals that work
with me that we're we're a great team
I'm gonna love these kids I'm gonna go
home man
some of that is Shifting your
expectations on what the workplace is
supposed to provide to you I'm going to
get my friendships and my community and
my connections outside of here I also
know the reality for a special ed
teacher
um I taught in a co-taught classroom
uh for a couple years there's multiple
adults in that classroom you it you have
to rely on the community outside you're
there at 7 00 a.m you leave at 7 00 PM
you're there all day right
um that's your world man and it's no
good when you can't walk down the hall
and say hi and people just go like we're
on Mean Girls part two or something like
that so
uh I I can't tell you because I don't
live in your situation and I wouldn't
tell you whether you quit or not
I don't see it as a failure I don't see
it as a moral you're somehow less of
character if you leave
that's you just saying I want to have a
better life
I did the right thing y'all can be
immature I want to have a better life
and good special ed teachers are so hard
to come by you will have another job
before you can you can blink
I also don't have any problem with you
trying to Crest above it
I'm gonna continue to be nice and smile
and wave
and if y'all want to continue to give me
the silence treatment it's not treatment
like we're in sixth grade then you're
welcome you're welcome to burden
yourselves with that I'm not gonna do
that I'm going to continue continue to
love kids be a great professional be a
great colleague and if I see something
else
that I think is abusive I'm gonna reach
out I'm gonna do it every single time so
um sorry you're in this in this in this
pickle man it's it's no fun but I'm
really proud of you for doing the hard
thing following your gut even though it
hey it may not it ended up there was
nothing actionable here what was what
you thought was happening wasn't
happening
I still applaud your bravery for seeing
something
and saying something
all of us could do that a little bit
more thank you so much for the call